omicron and not too many answers we'll
try and furnish you with uh some right
now because all day here on sky news
we've been receiving your questions on
the booster rollout and the omicron
variant itself we've assembled now a
panel of experts to try to answer some
of those questions uh joining us now are
dr yasso brown gp and diversity lead for
the doctors association also mark jeet
professor of vaccine epidemiology at the
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine and a member of the sage
subcommittee on modeling and dr mukesh
kapila professor of global health and
humanitarian affairs at the university
of manchester and former director with
the world health organization very good
to have you all here so much to get
through and as you know i'm sure so many
questions about omicron and booster so
let's get to it our first question is
coming from eddie and i'm going to put
this to all of you because there are
many parts to it i suppose well at least
two and dr brown if i can start with you
with eddie's question it is this omicron
is more contagious but it also seems
milder why is treatment for cancer and
heart disease being put on the back
burner while the booster program is
being prioritized and of course uh ugps
are on the front line of the the booster
rollout so omicron more contagious but
it seems milder so why then other
treatments put on the back burner
thank you for your question eddie i'd
say japanese study has found that it's
4.2 times more contagious than the delta
variant i know that in south africa
they're coming out and advising that it
is milder but we don't know what degree
it is and we're finding that um even
though that there is some degree of
evasion that actually there is still um
an importance in getting the booster um
in terms of immune protection and i
understand the anxieties about pausing
the nhs
routine and elective care that's sort of
being discussed at the moment and that
was on um sky just now
um and um you know no no one wants to
see um any any more further delays but
actually we've also got to do uh with
this issue of um understanding how much
um omicron might push and push us back
and that's why i i believe it's being
done
let's get professor jeet said take on
that bit of it the idea that omicron
could be more contagious but milder now
a few months ago we were hoping to reach
the position where we not where we would
get a variant that would be perhaps a
little as omicron seems at the moment
something that we might be able to live
with and would spread
immunity without vaccination could this
be it or is it definitely not
unfortunately it's too early to say
whether this variant is milder we have
had reports from south african hospitals
that doctors are seeing
patients who are less likely to have the
most severe
sort of symptoms but the problem is that
a lot of these patients they're seeing
are re-infections these are patients who
have had covet before and are now
getting infected again because omicron
is able to evade their immunity whereas
in previous waves they had patients who
were getting colbit for the very first
time so what we don't know is whether
these patients are just having milder
disease because they're re-infections
they have a little bit of immunity which
isn't enough to protect them from
getting omicron but is enough to protect
them against the worst effects it will
be i think a few weeks before we can
actually compare like with like a
patient who doesn't have any immunity
who got say delta versus a patient who
didn't have any immunity who got omicron
and see whether it really is milder at
the moment we just have to conclude that
we don't know that yet unfortunately
dr capulet one thing is for sure even as
we don't know the effect that omicron is
going to have on hospitalizations we do
know the effect that the resources of
the nhs been turned to this emergency
booster program are going to lead to
more backlogs with already a pretty dire
situation
indeed absolutely and really this is all
about numbers even if omicron
does prove beyond reasonable doubt
that it is milder and
it's going to take time to do that
but because it's highly contagious the
number of people who will get kirk over
19 is going to be measured in in
millions if that happens then by even if
it is not as fatal as previous variants
the sheer numbers involved in terms of
hospitalization are bound to be high
hence the concern
that it is much better to be proven
there's another factor i think even if
we start boosting everyone today because
the number of people in the uk who
haven't yet had even their second
vaccine is not that very high and then
of course it's going to take time to get
to the millions done with the booster
booster job there is bound to be a gap
between boosted immunity and
the burden on
on healthcare systems
here's a question uh following on from
that very interesting point dr capila
from phil uh asks and it's supposed it's
it it's a logical uh response to to the
effect of vaccinations so far certainly
two of them and certainly if they're
astrazeneca uh on omicron phil asks what
is the point of vaccine passports if you
can still get covid when fully
vaccinated um
you'll feel on that dr brown
yeah and firstly a line of this sort of
questioning um i feel often is about
distrust as well and i think that in
recent years um i think our leadership
does need to really build that back
um so i am sorry for those that it is
causing anxiety and and feeling of the
liberties and that sort of thing however
um just like we have national passports
that we are able to travel it's the same
sort of line and it's a way of basically
safeguarding and safeguarding the
protection that we've built in um with
with all the different mitigations not
just vaccinations
dr kevin your view on that um if you can
still get covered when you're fully
vaccinated what is the point of
a vaccine passport
this whole exercise is about
risk and exposure management
so what that means is that if you've had
your two jobs and hopefully your third
job as well the chances of you getting
a bad covet
are much reduced now i actually spend a
lot of my time uh in continental europe
in france italy and so on and where the
kovid
pass is in common use going to
restaurants and so on and so forth and
while one can understand some of the
concerns around the freedoms and the
introduction of
of id cards and those kinds of things
quite honestly this is very small price
to pay and i think uh having a a
certificate which says that you had your
basic immunizations is still some
protection and some security when using
crowded public places
yeah so and there's a very big
difference as you say there between
getting coveted and ending up in the
hospital and getting covered and shaking
it off after a few days or a week or so
i've got a very specific question here
for you i'm going to put it to you
professor jeet i think you might be best
placed to answer this for us and it's
from
paul uh in norwich and he says my
partner and son contracted kovid around
three to four weeks ago does this mean
they're going to be protected through
natural antibodies against omicron i
suppose the thought being that omicron
may have been around you know a bit
longer than before we we first formally
identified it so three to four weeks ago
they they both had covered could they
have natural antibodies against omicron
well the first thing i'd say is if they
were in the uk and it was three to four
weeks ago it was probably not omicron i
mean there was omicron around in the
world but the number of cases in the uk
was probably very very low at that time
so they probably got delta
that means that they do not have very
good protection against omicron i would
say that they're likely to have some
protection so the risk of getting
armicron is less than someone who's
never had covet before at all but i
would say that their risk is not zero
they still have a fair chance of getting
it so i would still you know be careful
going to christmas parties maybe you
know get tested before you go to a big
party just to protect other people there
i mean they might and and please i would
also recommend them to get the booster
if they have
haven't haven't had it yet so they have
a lower risk probably because the
antibodies will give them a bit of
protection but because omicron is so
good at evading the immunity we had from
previous strains they don't have
perfect or even very high protection
just on that professor gene how long do
you have to wait after suffering from
covid to get your booster
well i i
think it's i i think
it'd be best to ask um the the gp but i
think it's about three weeks after that
they straight up get it then dr brown um
it is recommended isn't it to um wait a
while until you you get a booster if you
have been diagnosed as having suffered
from covid recently
um that might just be to suppress having
um
more of a reaction um i i i don't
actually um
want my mind about what the exact um
time frame of distance is i'm sure it's
there uh i'm sure it's there on the
government website but just to stay with
you dr brown i want to
put for this next question uh to you all
with omicron rising uh question coming
from whatsapp it's a question on many
thousands many millions of people's lips
how likely is it that we will go into
another lockdown which if i can turn
that question around is do you think
plan b and uh what may follow if it's
plan c do you think they will work
against omicron or might we need to go
full lockdown dr brown
yeah i mean
i have thought about this um and i would
say that actually we're not a covered
naive society anymore so
um we have not just exposure but we've
got learning from from what we've always
seen so
and what we want to do is make sure that
we are protecting the most vulnerable
with the information that we've had the
learning that we've had but also put
into the mitigations that we know work
so hand you know hand hygiene face masks
social distancing um
companies to look into ventilation asked
to think about ventilation
as well as
engaging in the vaccine program and so
just i think we just all need to take
that responsibility and apply our
knowledge um and actually
we would probably won't in my opinion i
think because of the mitigations that we
have and and where we are we're not
killed naive i i don't think um
that i think the lockdown is sort of a
really last resort but obviously we've
got people here from sage and to vho
that
would definitely be able to
advise on this further well let's have a
look with dr cabula about that um
let me put it another way presumably
another full lockdown can never really
be entirely ruled out
well knockdowns can't be ruled out but
with the current state of knowledge that
we have
and all the tools at our disposal
and the current spread i do not think a
decision on lockdowns today if taken
today
would be
justified and remember also that the
experience of the last two years shows
that all that lockdowns do
is postpone or delay the spread of
infections so
what happens is when you do lockdowns
and people are not exposed to virus
and if they haven't had their their jab
then they will
certainly not get the virus but as soon
as they go out into the real world
they'll get it if they've not been
vaccinated
so what that means is that
lockdowns never have been the answer
and thank god we are we've moved on a
great deal from that particular state i
would be extremely surprised if a
lockdown decision argument is made by
sage or others
as being imminent and i think if the
booster program goes even half as much
half as well
as it is uh
as a target indicates then i would very
much doubt that there will be a log done
or should be a long time okay professor
g you give me your thoughts on that
briefly and i'm going to add in because
there's so many good questions here i
want to get as many as i i can in here
and this is a very specific question and
uh i'm very interested in it in that i'm
in this position if i've had two
astrozenica vaccines can i get the fisa
vaccine as my booster i've actually had
that and how much protection does that
mixing and matching offer
well i in fact the boosters that are
being given are all pfizer and modern
vaccines and these have been tested in
trials now with people who have had
either astrazeneca or pfizer vaccines
and they've been found to give very good
protection to either group of people so
this mixing and matching actually works
it's been found to be safe and give very
good protection in trial so definitely
um the mix and match um as as you put it
um does work
um on the question of the look
happy to for you to continue
sorry i interrupted you a thought on
lockdown potential or of another
lockdown
yeah i mean i can't say because that's
really the government's decision to make
and i don't have special insight into
what they might decide but i would say
well they have to take many things into
consideration the health impact which um
the signs don't look great because there
is going to be a big wave of omicron but
they also have to take into account the
economy the effect on people's lives and
mental health and so forth i would say
we're in a better position than we were
a year ago or because we have the
vaccines and even though we know that
this variant is good at evading vaccines
we know that if people get the booster
then that does
boost their protection up to a level
that does help to protect them against
omicron so we are in a better position
if people get boosted than we were
at the start of the pandemic and dr
brown you must be getting asked that a
lot i suppose about people coming in
given the millions upon millions of
people in the uk who've had two
astrozenica jobs now as we hear from
professor jeet they're um getting uh
pfizer and moderner
asking that
precise question am i still as protected
if i've had three pfizers or three mod
earners
uh yasu um jcvi have basically done
studies to show about mixed vaccinations
and they've approved it um and um also
mhra have approved visa
visa astrazeneca and moderna asbesto
vaccines and so uh generally we would be
reassuring people that mixed
vaccinations are fine if they have
medical reasons to have astrazeneca then
that will be continued
got a question i'm trying to squeeze as
many as
i say got a question here from dan he
says he's got covid right now
poor you dan and assumes it is the delta
variants
not sure he asks if people who recover
from delta can succumb to omicron
immediately afterwards uh particularly
as he came to see people at christmas as
so many millions are so he's got delta
is he in danger still then from omicron
immediately afterwards do we know
i'm
guessing we don't do dr capula
well i think if you had a previous
strain then obviously you've got some
immunity you've got t-cell immunity as
well not just the antibodies so
one more the first principle i guess
would say that surely your body is fired
up immunologically speaking but of
course you're vulnerable to omicron
because there's a completely different
uh
variant when you would get your omicron
having just got your delta i'm not sure
i have the knowledge to give the answer
to that if anyone ever
if anyone else does but yes you are
vulnerable to omicron even if you have
the delta violence
and professor g dom that i suppose we go
back to
whatever the situation is after your
natural infection do get your
vaccination as well get your booster as
well
yes definitely in fact there have been
studies looking at antibodies showing
that people who have had a previous
infection and then got vaccinated have
even more protection than people who
just had either natural infection or
just vaccination
and uh dr brown a quick thought a
specific one and again you must see
patients in this
situation antoinette is pregnant had her
first dose six weeks ago and she asked
why the government isn't reducing the
period between first and second doses
because she obviously wants to protect
herself she's pregnant and had a first
dose six weeks ago
yeah well first of all congratulations
tonight um and what i would say is it's
really difficult situation um it's um
i'm just thinking back to what
christopher t said when um we've talked
about these vaccine gaps and maybe going
against the fisa 21 day recommendation
it's about it's a public health
management it's a public health approach
basically and it's about health equity
it's about looking at um how long
um it will last within our immune system
or help our immune system rather
and also it's going to be about a
vaccine supply as well
brilliant stuff thank you so much we
packed so much in the short time
available thank you so much my esteemed
panel dr brown professor jeet dr kapila
we are eternally grateful thank
you uh